[inaudible]
joining me today is the Milbank family
centers senior fellow at the Hoover
Institution at Stanford University,
a senior fellow at the Center for
European studies at Harvard where he also
served as a professor of history for 12
years as well as the author of 14 books.
Neil Ferguson. Welcome to the Rubin
report. It's exciting to be here.
How'd I do on the intro there? I mean I
was looking through your bio 14 books.
There were 87 other things I
could have credited you for.
We've already done an interview here in
just the 15 minutes we've been sitting
here. How was that all right. I mean
I could've just made it quicker.
The better is my feeling
about introductions just to
set. He is Neil. All right,
here's Neil. All right. There's
a ton we got to cover here and I,
we've already done half of it
I think without the cameras.
So let's just dive in immediately to
the culture war stuff cause I can tell
you've been traveling a lot.
Half jet lags, half wide awake,
but I can see that's really where
your head's at at the moment.
So let's talk some culture war stuff.
What do you feel is happening sort of
in the gestalt of the universe at the
moment?
We'll look assaulted.
The university might be where we should
begin since I've spent a lot of my life
in universities. You mentioned a couple
of them that Stanford and Harvard.
I was at Oxford before that and I'm,
much of my life has been,
I think witnessing the gradual
homogenization of academic life,
especially in the field like history.
When I became a historian back in the
1980s in Oxford and then in Cambridge,
it was generally accepted that that could
be conservative historians and liberal
historians and socialist historians
and then some oxys and towards,
it was really quite a heterogeneous
community, Oxbridge in those days.
And if you,
uh,
as I was attracted to the Conservatives
because they were more fun and it was a,
I think I can say more right?
But on more fun.
The Fun was the initially
attractive thing.
When I first got to Oxford
in the early eighties,
it was clearly at the funniest
people where the facture rights, uh,
the young Andrew Sullivan who was
a year ahead of me at Moreland.
So this was all great fun and
it led to intellectual, uh,
insight because they turned
out all sorts of B writes,
the historians take Bob Conquest,
who was then at the Hoover institution,
one of the few historians who got
the Soviet Union right at the time,
who wrote about Stalin's crimes not
long after they were perpetrated.
I mean, those were the
heroes, uh, of my early years.
But in the course of my career,
what has happened has been that one
history department after another has moved
steadily and relentlessly
to the monochrome left.
And it has become steadily harder to,
to be seen as a conservative.
I say seen us, cause I,
I've never really felt
that I'm a conservative,
but I've often been as one to be seen
as a conservative historian has become
steadily harder and harder.
And as a result,
the culture war to use your phrase in the
universities has been won by the left.
There will really be soon a handful left
of conservatives at institutions like
Harvard and Stanford and Harvey Mansfield
will probably be the last one at
Harvard. Uh, and, and that's
to me deeply depressing,
deeply troubling. Do you remember a
moment when you saw that shift occurring,
because you're saying in the,
in the 80s, mid eighties,
it was pretty diverse in terms of ideas.
Do you remember seeing something or did
you see markers that started that you
can start putting together the map
of where this thing was going to go?
I think the definition of defeat in the
culture war is that it's imperceptible
that you're,
you're aware of it a little bit each
year because in a typical department each
year somebody retires or dies.
Uh,
but they're always replaced
with somebody working on that.
Say for the sake of argument,
gender history. So you,
your colleague was,
uh,
was lecturing on the history of
the Soviet Union. Richard Pipes,
who was at Harvard and uh,
and just lately died,
one of the great historians
of the Bolshevik revolution.
You don't ever see someone like that
replaced with somebody like him.
There'll always be replaced by
somebody working on gender history,
native American history,
that,
that process whereby there was no
replacement of conservative historians,
was a more or less annual events.
I got accustomed to
being in a real minority,
a minority of conservative,
uh, historians.
I got accustomed to losing
pretty much every vote.
Being in the minority on every committee.
It became a kind of,
you've got to climatize to it,
and then one day suddenly hit you that
you were practically the last one left.
Uh, and you know, when
I moved to Stanford, the
revelation was quite startling.
I was invited to come to
the Hoover institution.
Many Hoover fellows serve associations,
uh,
joint appointments with
Stanford departments.
I had been pretty successful
as a teacher at Harvard.
My classes had been very large.
Uh,
the students gave me very
powerful evaluations. Uh,
I kind of assumed that I would come to
Stanford and have some relationship with
the history department. And then I
was told, oh, no, no, none at all,
not even a courtesy appointment.
And it was clear that that moment that
I had become in the eyes of the Stanford
History Department, a
pariah, somebody who,
who simply couldn't be allowed
in the building because of my,
my conservative leanings.
Can you explain little bit more about how
the universities work like that, that,
that could even happen? They're going to,
they're going to bring you in. You're,
you're a fellow there and that you're
just going to be ignored by the department
that you're an expert in.
It's quite insulting,
especially as you've mentioned.
Uh,
as I've published all there are lots of
boutiques. Yeah. Find rather more than,
than most of the department put together.
And I think,
uh,
a department with falling enrollments
might have been expected to,
to want to have a me playing apart.
But what happened is,
and it's happened in most departments
and most universities inexorably the left
to Kovar and an implicit rule,
a tacit rule was,
uh,
impose that one does not hire
right leaning, uh, historians,
nor does one hire. They're
graduate students so that they too,
people who have been my graduate
students have found it difficult, uh,
to get hired.
So it's essentially a straightforward,
a process whereby the institution has
taken over one committee at a time and the
left has been good at that for the
better part of a century. They've all,
how do you think they saw that? How did
they have the foresight to go, all right,
we've got to take over
the university's first.
I think that on the right,
uh,
the previous generation of historians,
and this was also true of philosophers
and people working in other fields,
did not fight very hard,
uh,
or effectively to promote their
successes in academic life.
You need to be mindful of the succession.
The left was better at
ensuring that it's Pratap.
Jay's got the appointments. Ultimately,
academia is a committee's game.
It's all about getting to be the chair
of the department to be in charge of the
committees. If you control the
process, you control the selection,
you control the recruitment.
And I suppose I'm,
I'm such a naive person.
I kind of in my youth assumed we were an
abroadly meritocratic world in which if
you were smart and hardworking,
then then good things would would happen
and it took me off for your, yeah,
I was completely naive.
It took me a while to cottoned
onto the fact that in in reality,
in academic life as another walks of
life patronages everything and you can be
as talented as you like if you're
not in the right patronage network,
then you're done. And I suppose it's
been thinking about these issues,
how do networks capture institutions
that that led me to write the most recent
book,
the square and the tower,
which is actually book number 15 to try
to think about how networks operate.
We tend to talk casually about networks,
but I came to realize that in academic
life has another areas you need to
understand quite exactly quite precisely
how networks operate to see how power
is truly wielded.
We can all see the hierarchical
institutions that are
where power is located.
I mean, universities are clearly
not as powerful as as governments,
but the critical point is
to understand the disease.
Often networks that capture institutions,
the capture, the hierarchies,
and that's what happened in academic life.
And now I think pretty soon they're just
won't be conservatives in university
departments.
More importantly than that,
nobody will be teaching subjects
like the history of the Soviet Union.
So no students will be taught about the
crimes of Lenin and Stalin and students.
Like the students I taught yesterday will
not hear from anybody that there was a
religious motivation
to the nine 11 attacks.
I had a class at Stanford yesterday and
was allowed to sit in and teach somebody
else's class as a guest professor.
And it happened to be a
discussion about nine 11. Uh,
and it became clear to me
that the students had never
considered the possibility
that there was a religious motivation,
uh,
to the nine 11 attacks.
Uh,
and more or less accepted the idea that
they were retaliation for the misdeeds
of US foreign policy in the Middle East,
what are called the Howard Zinn theory.
And since Howard Zinn's books are more
widely read in the United States than
anybody else's history books,
we therefore arrive at a situation in
which there will be nobody in any measure
university saying,
actually Howard Zinn is completely wrong
and this is not what nine 11 was about.
So that's what I find depressing when I
say that the culture was kind of over in
the universities.
That's really what I mean.
Yeah. So let's circle back because
it does bring us to your 15th work.
I stand corrected. Um, this
I this idea of networks,
because we were talking right before
we started that there is something
happening here with this loose association
of people that has been coined the
intellectual dark web.
And I said to you when you walked in,
are you part of the intellectual dark
web as if you were going to give me a
secret handshake or a special card or
when I was, I denied all knowledge.
Yeah.
The assumption that it was secret and
then it turned out to be all over the New
York Times. Yeah, but are you weren't,
you weren't photographed in
the bushes like the rest of us,
but I suspect that you secretly are
in the intellectual dark web. Well,
I couldn't possibly reveal
that because it's secret.
But when you said something
interesting about,
because of your level of academic sort
of academic credit that you thought
perhaps that took you out of it.
But then Christina Hoff Summers
said something interesting.
I don't know who goes in there,
what
Barry was emailed me on,
my wife Ayaan Hirsi Ali,
who's been on your show is much more
interesting than me is the greatest.
And I mean, we, she must be
tough for you because, you know,
it's like the millions of people
love your work and everything else,
but it's like ion is like transcended.
She's wonderful. It's tough.
It's the most enormous,
wonderful blessing in my life to be
married to somebody who's just way more
interesting than me. At best
they're looking to. So that,
so we were both asked by Barry, uh,
why supplant the intellectual dark web?
And I said, look, how can I
really claim to be part of that?
When I taught for 12 years at Harvard,
left of my own volition and here at
Stanford can write newspaper columns and
have them published more or
less where I want it would,
it would be a little disingenuous to
claim kinship with people like Bret
Weinstein who've been persecuted by the
academic left. Now I've been attacked.
I've been criticized, but I haven't
really been driven underground,
at least not at this point. But
Christina's summers said to me, uh,
just the other night.
No,
it's not about whether you've been
denied a platform or not. Clearly,
almost all the people in the article
that Barry wrote have plenty of
opportunities to make their views known.
It's about whether you are seen to speak
for people who feel that they have been
silenced, who feel that their
voices aren't heard night.
That's quite a good definition
of what this is about,
but you're also right to see that it's
a network. As I was reading the article,
I was thinking how funny
I know all these people.
I'm the sole exception of Jordan
Peterson who I've never met. Um,
I sent that's coming. Well, yeah, I
hope so. I look forward to it. Um,
but I, I, I think it's a
network of the most, uh,
ideal sought.
It is a truly informal network of
people from right across the political
spectrum because nobody could call Bret
Weinstein are conservatives who have
come together spontaneously,
informally.
Nobody called it into being and said,
I'm forming the intellectual dark web,
turn up on Monday at 5:00
PM and I does it change?
Does it change the second it's name?
Generally a network.
So if this is the right type of network,
right,
it's cool kind of diverse group of
people who had all sorts of different
motivations and everything else.
Once it's sort of named,
does that change the way a network
has to operate? Cause I sent,
that's what the discussion is
about right now, although not, not.
I think fundamentally that the critical
thing is when something ceases to be
secret.
I tell the story of the Illuminati,
a network in the late 18th century in
Germany that sought to advance a radical
version of the enlightenment but
covertly as a secret organization. Uh,
the intellectual dark web,
um,
I semi seriously said was secrets until
Barry wrote that and now that it's out
in the,
in the open,
what will happen is that it will grow
because people are Andrew Sullivan.
I was discussing with him to a
said, hmm, why am I [inaudible]?
And of course the answer is, but you
should be ready. I mean, anybody who,
who is engaged in critical thinking
about the whole range of ideas,
uh, in our society ranging from the
political to the social and cultural,
anybody who is in the debate and is
antagonistic to the dogmas of the left,
uh, the political correctness,
the identity politics,
the spurious pursuit of so called
social justice. If you are skeptical,
if you are thinking critically
about the dogmas of the left,
then you belong in the intellectual dark
web because you're the kind of person
who at some point will be no platformed,
who at some point will be taken down.
Who at some point will be the target
of a hit piece in the New York Times.
One of the characteristic features of
the intellectual dark whereby think is
that most members at one time or another
have fallen foul of the leftist thought
police.
And as soon as you've had that experience,
it's happened to me a number of times.
That is quite transformative. Yeah,
I mean it literally changed my life.
It's the only reason you're sitting here
right now. I was once one of them and,
and I suspect that your
experience was like mine.
You're kind of taken aback to be on the
receiving end of a social media mob.
You're kind of taken aback to be attacked,
not for the substance of anything
that you've argued or written or said.
You're attacked for your reputation,
you're attacked for
your alleged bad faith.
And each time this has happened to
me, I've, I've been a little stunned.
I was naive.
Not only was I a believer in meritocracy,
I was also a believer that we were engaged
in irrational debate about the past.
That's what historians do.
Uh,
and that one made ones case
presented the evidence.
And then the other side did the same.
But I wrote a book,
a book about the British Empire.
Now what, 15 or so years ago,
an argument,
their argument of that book was that not
everything about the British empire was
bad than there are benefits as
well as costs to imperialism.
And I never had a debate
about that argument.
I only ever was attacked by the left
for being an apologist of empire,
a neocolonialist, et cetera. Uh,
and so in that curious debate that
that is central to the cultural war,
you never really are engaged with
on the ideas or the evidence.
It is always about whether
you have bad faith or not,
whether you are covertly
racist and Islamophobe,
uh, our homophobe that there's a long
list of things that you can be accused of.
But those are the most popular ones.
Ones never really discussing
the arguments of the books.
One's always discussing the
personality of the author. Yeah.
So this is just sort of simply put the
ideas verse people conversation. Right.
So in a, in a case of a violin, I mean,
to live through the things that she has
lived through between FTM and her and
her and her friend being
murdered and the whole thing, uh,
to be called the things that she's called.
I mean,
it flips you're very personhood
on its head, which is,
I mean, it's, it's so deeply twisted.
The episode for me brought it
into bold relief was the Brandeis,
uh,
honorary degree fiasco when ion was
invited by the president of Brandeis.
And this was in 2014. Yeah. Except an
honorary degree in speak at commencement.
And then,
uh,
was very publicly and humiliatingly
disinvited under pressure from an unholy
alliance as far as I could see of leftists
and Islamists who set out online to
smear her reputation with the usual
confection of selective quotation and,
and misrepresentation.
And as often happens in these situations,
the university authorities
capitulate without a fight, uh,
to the left and, and they do it
publicly. And that that for me was,
uh,
that was a moment when I learned a lot
about what was going wrong in American
academic life and realize that it's,
it's the combination of,
of aggressive activists on the left,
um,
and useful idiots in, in university
bureaucracies [inaudible] fold.
Is it that they're useful
idiots or is it just,
is it just sort of blanket cowardice by,
I'm part of some of the academics,
but really the,
the administrators and the upper brass
at all the schools and the fact that the
donors, although this is changing right
now and as we're taping this today,
I know it's going to be out
in a couple of days. Um,
evergreen is now firing a
whole bunch of professors,
which is exactly whatever
what all of us predicted,
basically because the donors have
just had enough. It's fascinating.
So it's hard to figure out where
does it come? Just cowardice.
Cowardice is the most powerful
force in human history, no doubt.
And I'm constantly amazed at just
how much cowardice is out there.
Uh, my wife's experience has
shown me that the, the, the,
the difficulty of getting people publicly
to support her work against Islamic
extremism is all about cowardice,
fear of being in any way drawn
into, into the, the real war,
the Jihad, uh, facing the death threats
that she has repeatedly had to face.
But it's not just cowardice. Uh,
there is a good deal of complicity.
Many university administrators
are themselves ideologically
on the left and feel
that they have a mission
to empower, uh, the,
the leftists in the
student body. Uh, and this,
I think a different thing
from, from Canada. So yeah,
I think,
I think this is a fascinating
moment in time because donors,
alumni look at what is going
on, uh, on university campuses,
as do people who have not had the
privilege of university education,
who see it all as complete
madness and ask the question,
what the hell is going on here? And I
think the more that question gets asked,
the better.
But we should not underestimate
the massive inertia in the system.
It is extremely hard. Even if you're a
university president, you say, right,
I'm going to clean house. It's really
hard to do because they're all tenured.
I mean, the faculty is tenured, it's
everywhere. You know what I mean?
Like we don't find, oh well, you know,
in the northeast it's a little
bit better than, you know,
just even geographically, we
just don't even see that. Yes,
there are bastions of freedom. I've
heard University of Chicago or you know,
like a couple of places
are a little bit better,
but how do you think it
actually spread that way?
That it wasn't just here and there and
there's a theory that universities are
always left wing, but that's
not true of, for example,
if you had been in Germany in the 1920s,
uh,
the universities were
bastions of conservatism, uh,
an extreme and indeed extreme
right wing nationalism,
which is one reason that universities
very quickly went over to the Nazi regime
when Hitler came to power.
So there's no golden rule
that says universities have
to be left wing Oxford and
Cambridge, ah, in the 18th century
works extraordinary reactionary,
uh, fundamentally religious institutions
and deeply Tory with a few exceptions in
there in the politics. So
there's no rule rule here. Uh,
I think the best explanation I can
offer you is a process of generational
capture of education institutions dating
from the 1960s universities in let's
take the elite universities,
the Ivy League universities in the 1950s.
We're already seen as being liberal.
Um,
and if you were a kind of
McCarthy leaning Republican,
you already knew that Harvard was
likely full of fellow travelers,
um,
and a covert commies.
But the real shift I think came later.
I think it came with the antiwar
protests of the late sixties and early
seventies.
The more radical baby boomers who were
protesting in the campuses and 68 s into
the early seventies,
uh,
grew up to become professors
nested around. Uh,
and I think that generation,
which was essentially formed at
the time of the antiwar protests,
successfully replicated itself.
They were very,
very good at replicating themselves by
creating graduate students in their own
image and then making
sure that those graduates,
students got jobs and the
right was nowhere. So you are,
you are out there writing books,
doing research and figuring, well,
all right,
they're doing that.
And maybe in the long run on my
heroes at Oxford and Cambridge who,
who wrote great books and
we're also politically active
people like Norman stone
or Roger Scruton who did
much of the thinking that uh,
that accompanied that
tourism in the 1980s.
What they did not do well was academic
politics. They were poor at that. Uh,
they were poor at succession planning.
And that is,
I think the best explanation I can
offer for the fact that in nearly all
universities in North
America and in Europe,
90% plus of faculty members are
Liberals or progressives if not outright
Marxists.
All right.
So with some of the historical
context of how this all happened,
I know you are enthused about this new
network idea and because it's come around
the right way,
do you think there's a gatekeeping
responsibility for whoever is involved in
this?
This seems to be one of the hot button
issues with this thing are who can be in
this whatever it is. What are the
ideas that cannot be on the inside? Uh,
I see it coming much more than that.
We have to watch out for ideas
on the right than on the left.
That seems to be the way it's being
framed, at least from where I sit. Um,
how would you do that in a, in a proper
network monitoring out two kinds of,
of of networks,
open access networks.
Let's take the example of Facebook
where you can just join up and open a
Facebook account. You can even
do it as a fake human being. Um,
and then there are the
restricted access networks, uh,
extreme cases. The
secret societies of, uh,
of the 18th and 19th century don't
really have many analogs today cause it's
hard to do anything secret in secrecy,
barely exists any,
any more in the age of,
of wikileaks.
So you have to I think decide whether
to be an open or closed or restricted
access network and the minute you
are restricted access network,
somebody is making the decisions about
who joins that then ends up being the,
the membership committee and then
you were just a club. Really.
I don't think that's an option in,
in our time.
I think an open access networks,
the only real way to go, um,
and you must accept that if the, uh, if
the intellectual dot Webb is, is real,
that it's an open access network that
won't necessarily connect you to everybody
that you want to be connected to and
may connect you to people that you
positively don't want to be connected to.
This has been a central
problem I think of, uh,
being on the political
right for a long time.
I can remember in the 1980s when
people said to me, well, Neil,
you're a conservative.
And I would say, well,
I'm actually not a member
of the Conservative Party.
I think of myself as a classical liberal.
They would say, oh, but nevertheless,
when I look at all the things you say,
you're a conservative.
And then I would think,
what does that mean?
That I have to have
dinner with the likes of,
I would think of various egregious
conservative members of parliament. Um,
and it was as if you would be associated
with those people even if you never had
dinner with them. And it's the same
problem now except that it's, it's,
it's worse now because the way in
which the left seeks to discredit it,
uh,
you and Jordan Peterson and probably
me as well at another number,
your show is to say scared man.
I mean 15 blinds say,
look at the People Paul,
who are connected to these people who
quote these people or who read their
books, um, that there they are over there,
but terrible alt right. And you
know, when you say, all right, the,
the audience is supposed to start
booing and hissing and you know,
Steve Bannon is supposed to appear in
a black robe with the Saife, you know,
I am deaf.
So I think that the problem is I think
in escapable there will be a constant
effort on the left to say that uh,
the intellectual dark web is just
some kind of a facade in front of an,
a hideous outright,
which is composed of remember
racists Islamophobes homophobes.
Um, and that will be the
culture wars next. Yeah,
I mean that was straight works.
We have a strange amount of gay people
and Muslim people and yeah, absolutely.
But there you go. Otherwise Brown people
in every other type of thing is self,
the self hating phenomenon.
The left is low, long
known. How to say that it is
absolutely typical of the wicked,
right? That they should have
lewd into that to the side,
uh, self hating and then you just fill
in the blank. Self hating Muslims,
self hating gays.
That's how this works.
You remember they lost all the arguments.
All they've got left is
reputational smearing man.
We've got to fight in front of us. Huh.
You know, I, I have lost sleep about this.
Not only because people
threatened my wife's life.
That's the real war that the war
against the Islamic extremists is no,
is no mere culture wards and actual war.
I've also lost sleep about the Maya
culture war at the prospect of,
of the reputational attacks.
It's,
it's never pleasant to be
attacked as I was recently,
uh, in effect for being
a, I guess a sexist,
racist or a racist sexist,
because I'd organize a conference
at which all the speakers, uh,
where white men,
because the women I invited
couldn't come. And, uh,
that was a private conference,
wasn't supposed to.
It wasn't even as a kind of
informal discussion about
how we could take the idea
of applied history and make history more
relevant to some of the debates that go
on. I think a lot of what has done in
academic history these days is not really
relevant to anything terribly much,
but this event was a rather crudely
exposed in the New York Times and the
Washington Post,
uh,
the pictures of the speakers
were published as if the
mugshots as it appeared in
the New York Times. And the implication
was that I must be a terrible racist,
sexist, or sexist racist for
having organized such a conference.
I did lose sleep about that. Uh, and I,
I think that part of the
culture war is really,
is really odious because it is,
it is calculated to discredit
the targeted individuals.
And it is,
it's bad faith on the part of the
people who launched those attacks.
So what,
in my view,
what's happening with some of those gated
institutions when the newspapers that
used to be objective, you know, look,
Barry wrote this piece in the New York
Times that I think was a pretty fair
piece. It was even somewhat critical
of me, and I'm not above criticism,
so I'm certainly okay with that.
But then just a week later,
we see this awful piece about Jordan
and enforced monogamy and it's just
nonsense. I mean, it's just
nonsense. And you know,
I'm on tour with him right now and he
keeps explaining why that's course he
doesn't want anyone to be forced
to do anything and all that.
He's talking about marriage in
effect. Um, and, and Eric Weinstein,
our friend found two other references in
the history of the New York Times where
they talked about enforcement argument
and they were both positive relative to
progressive ideals. So it's like
they flip everything on its head.
But what do you think happened there?
I mean,
you're giving me a pretty good layout
of what's happened at the academic side,
but on the media side and those,
those gates, what is going on?
I spent a lot of my life doing
journalism because, um, I didn't have,
uh, any, uh, inherited money.
And being an academic in Britain in
the 1980s and nineties wasn't terribly
lucrative.
So I kept body and soul together.
Even from my graduate years writing for
newspapers and newspapers have had their
own transformation in the
course of my adult life.
Uh, and part of that sister economics,
as we all know, the business model,
which essentially revolved around
advertising has been an isolated by the
combination of Google and Facebook.
And these institutions are in some measure
in in desperation trying to reinvent
themselves for the Internet age and
everybody's in pursuit of clickbait,
even the gray lady, even the most
illustrious of, of newspapers.
And I think that's one explanation.
The other explanation is
that an institution like the
New York Times has its own
university, like character behaves
a little bit like university,
but the most self important newspapers
if you go to them are rather like
colleges.
And it's also true of the Financial Times,
which is that like a kind of Cambridge
college that sort of ended up by mistake
in London. And so they have some of
the same dynamics as, as universities.
And I think that's especially true of the
New York Times is also true of the BBC
incidentally. So institutions
like the times and the BBC, uh,
think of themselves as
being liberal bastions.
But for them, liberalism is truth. Uh,
it's the same problem at Harvard has,
if you've, if your motto is Veritas,
but you translate that into liberalism,
then by definition conservatives
and must be untruth.
And so I think there's a tendency and
it's there and in the New York Times
periodically to lash out against anyone
like Jordan Peterson who dissents from
liberal orthodoxy.
Remember,
part of what we're dealing here with is
a kind of quasar religious phenomenon.
The dogmas of the left have become more
and more religious in their quality as
they have been unmuted from that
fundamental economic rationality,
which was at the heart of Marxism,
when that all went down in flames in 1989,
the left decamped to the realm of culture.
And as it did that increasingly
to con the form of a cult.
And let me illustrate what I mean.
Cults define themselves partly by a belief
in a lot of things that are slightly
weird. In order to be in a cult,
you have to have some weird beliefs.
And one good example of a weird belief
is that sexuality is entirely constructed
socially and is not biologically rooted
and you can actually have any gender you
like and there are actually
multiple genders. Now that's absurd,
but to believe it has become a kind of
tests of your orthodoxy and on one sees
this at meetings are in academia in
which people introduce themselves by name
and by their preferred pronouns.
Now, when this first happened to me,
my immediate reaction was introduced
myself and say that my preferred pronouns
were it.
I restrain myself because I realized that
my sense of humor forged as it was in
Scotland in the 1970s is now almost
entirely politically incorrect.
And anything that I consider funny,
we'll get me into trouble.
But that has gone on in the media too.
And the other thing that's happened is
that the polarization which characterizes
a network society is now very visibly
there in the realm of newspapers and and
cable television.
One thing that we all got wrong about
the internet because we hadn't really
thought much about network science was
that we just assumed that if everybody
was connected,
everything would be awesome.
And that was the kind of mantra of
Silicon Valley for about 20 years.
But no network science tells you
that if you build a social network,
even quite a small one,
there will be something called homophily
because birds of a feather flock
together on bet you already
that the intellectual dark
web has two clusters that
are somewhat separate from one another.
I sent it happening right now immediately
and that's what happened in the media.
So as society became more
polarized politically,
so too did the media,
I think that's an,
that is one of the defining
characteristics of our age
that the polarization or
if you like self segregation that we see
online is translated into almost every
realm of life. Can there be any positives
out of that, out of that self selection
into finding groups that you're more
in common with that for at least for a
certain period of time?
There's some goodness there because you
can really sort of get into your ideas
enough to maybe leave the group
then and take those ideas out.
I think if you are in what
ever you want to call it,
the echo chamber or the filter bubble,
if you are in a cluster that cuts you
off from a contrary ideas you're lost.
Yeah.
What was fun about being in a network
of right leaning undergraduates in early
1980s Oxford was we're in constant
combat with the left-leaning Marxist.
There was still real Marxist is
then and we were far from cutoff,
constantly engaging with them and the
soggies Social Democrats in in the middle
and that was what made it interesting.
What I see happening in the networked
age is that people can retreat into a
realm of confirmation bias where they
hear only things that are similar to the
things they liked yesterday and the
algorithms are the key here where you are,
whether it's youtube or
on Facebook or on Twitter,
you are essentially going to be
fed more of what you already liked.
That's deeply intellectually unhealthy.
Just as a university
cannot be a university.
If everybody agrees about
first ideological principles
because how can you have
critical thinking in that environment?
So it's unhealthy for any
intellectual network to be Autarkic.
So the one thing the intellectual dark
web must not do is cut itself off from
other networks, including the
ones that hate us. I mean,
we have to be in an argument and we have
to have our minds constantly open to
the possibility that we're
wrong about some things.
And that's what I see more or less
disappearing from public life.
I recognize this at one
time, uh, when I was in, in,
in mortal combat with Paul
Krugman, the economist, uh,
turn journalists and realize that Koopman
could never admit that he'd ever been
wrong. And even when it was
obvious that he had been,
because he is part of this rezone,
Dettra was always being right
about everything. Did you have
to see the day that the article came out,
the original intellectual
dark web article by Barry?
The day that that came out that Paul
Krugman tweeted it and he tweeted this
thing about how we're also oppressed, you
know, just mocking everybody basically.
And then a bunch of us responded
to them and I of course,
retweeted it and invited him on the show.
I said, I'd be happy to discuss this,
you, and it gets a couple
of thousand retweets, but of
course, no response. Right.
And that you're right. That's what
we have to make sure we don't become.
But I think there's a,
uh,
there's a human trait that would sort
of make you want to retreat because it's
exhausting it having your motives attack
than your humanity attacked and lies
and smears and all the things that I
don't see anyone on this side doing.
I don't,
and that's an so it's an exhausting
fight because we're fading to different
battles. Yes. I'm supposedly the same
point. And they're symmetrical war. Yeah.
The moment in the sense that we haven't
recognized that in the culture war.
The only thing that works is
reputational destruction. I think we,
we are guaranteed sleepless nights.
Remember,
there's also the phenomenon of
guilty until proven innocent,
which is insidious and means that if
the reputational hit is bad enough,
uh, there may be no, uh, there
may be no recovery from it.
I was very struck by the speed with
which reputations were destroyed. Uh,
in the, the me two
movements, uh, most, uh,
very indolent phase.
Uh,
and a characteristic feature of the
process seemed to be that that men were
essentially guilty until proven
innocent and crimes were conflated with,
uh,
quite clearly non criminal behavior
in ways that were deeply troubling.
Uh, to my eyes, the false
accusation is of course the,
the ultimate nightmare of anybody
in this world at this time.
Because if you're falsely
accused, uh, well,
your reputation can be gone in 24
hours and that that has entered,
introduced into our lives something that
hasn't really existed since medieval
times.
Uh,
the feeling that we are at the mercy of
a wheel of fortune that can arbitrarily
turn against us and
dashes are over Turner's.
I think this makes the
culture war, uh, uh,
deeply troubling thing to be a part of.
And Mo,
most sensible, normal people say, God,
I want a quiet life.
Get me out of here. Uh,
and never involve me in any of this.
Get me off Twitter.
Get me off Facebook.
Never let my name appear
in the New York Times.
Never let me appear on a,
on a show like this because
it's just too dangerous. Uh,
I own need to say one thing that can be
taken out of context and represented as
heresy or hate speech
as heresy is now called,
cause that's what we now call heresy.
And I will be subjected to potentially
a weeks of vilification and maybe worse,
maybe the vilification will actually lead
me to lose my job at people are right
to be fearful of that.